Former vice presidential candidate and former
governor of Alaska, Sarah Palin, a big Trump
was interviewed by Good Morning Britain.
And it is absolutely nuts.
And, you know, I jokingly said 10 days ago
on Twitter, remember when Sarah Palin was
the craziest person in the Republican Party
back in 2008 and how now she seems so moderate
compared to some of this wacky Kuhnen stuff.
Then I saw this interview from yesterday and
now I'm thinking, no, no, Sarah Palin is just
as wacky as a lot of these Kuhnen people.
Let's look at some of some clips here will
die right in.
First question to Sarah Palin was, does Trump
bear responsibility for the January 6th riots?
The president told those who are attending
the rally to go protest peacefully and patriotically
and legally.
So no.
So these idiots who did stormed the Capitol
and now they're blaming the president for
their own actions.
I think that's a symptom of a societal problem
where people just cannot take responsibility
for their stupid and criminal acts.
The hilarity of Sarah Palin saying this is
about people being unable to take personal
responsibility for their actions.
That's what started this entire thing.
That's what got us here.
If on November 8th, which was the day that
the media called the election for Joe Biden,
if on November 8th, Donald Trump and Republicans
took responsibility and said, we lost, we
failed uncovered and we lost, or we didn't
do for whatever reason, we lost, and that's
it, that responsibility would have prevented
all of this.
And of course, after the fact in Trump's inciting
of the riot as well, they are completely denying
any responsibility whatsoever.
But that personal responsibility is not what
Sarah Palin is talking about.
She says that the problem with personal responsibility
is the people who did the rioting aren't taking
personal responsibility.
Then Sarah Palin makes the case that, listen,
the rioters were already there planning chaos.
They weren't influenced by Donald Trump at
all.
And Piers Morgan points out, well, hold on
a second.
The two months of the lie about election fraud
from November 4th, that was really the initial
catalyst for these people being so whipped
up to begin with.
This is why they were even there on January
6th.
It's a very good point.
Sarah Palin doesn't like it.
Also, you have to remember that those who
were these rioters and again, they are horrible
and they it was a horrible act.
They were there already.
So many of them were they were like standing
in the back of the rally rooting on patriotically
a president's speech.
No, they were they knew what they were going
to do.
They were going to go storm the capital.
And Bijur, the reason they were going to I'm
sorry, the reason Sarah Palin that we're going
to do that is because the president, ever
since the result of a fair democratic election,
had perpetuated an absolute lie that had been
widespread fraud, which has never been proven
at all.
It didn't exist.
He whipped his mob into a frenzy.
He told them to stop the steal.
And as the elected officials in Congress were
actually ratifying the election, he ordered
them to march down to the Capitol and stop
the steel.
And, yeah, some of them may have just got
the wrong memo.
But you know what?
It sounded to me like the president wanted
to stop the steel, as he put it, a stop, a
democratic election being ratified.
That, I'm afraid, is a criminal action, isn't
it?
Why are you generalizing, though, and making
it sound like it was this entire crowd that
was so excited because I saw thousands of
people?
Now this is just rich.
Why are you generalizing?
She says, well, he's not generalizing.
75 million people voted for Trump.
Piers isn't talking about 75 million people
because most of them stayed home on January
6th.
Thousands and thousands of people went to
the January 6th Trump rally.
Piers also isn't talking about all of them
because some of them, when the rally was over,
turned around and they went to their cars
or got on the subway and went home where they
came from.
He is doing the opposite of generalizing.
He's talking specifically about the people
who went to the Capitol and were trespassing
and vandalizing and being violent.
Was it five hundred people?
Was it 1500 people?
2000.
We're still trying to figure out the exact
number.
He's not generalizing at all.
And this continues.
And Sarah Palin won't even concede that Donald
Trump lost.
And this is where it you really see the full
delusion of Sarah Palin.
And I know some people are going to write
to me and say, David, she seems unwell.
She just she seems like she's not well.
And unfortunately, this is the impression
we get from a lot of these right wing loons.
So I don't know that that tells us much one
way or the other about her politics.
But she was asked Trump what Trump didn't
win.
Right.
Like Trump lost.
And she says, well, I don't know.
Take a look, Sarah.
I saw thousands of people.
I'm not generalizing.
We all sold the same general.
Thousands of people like it was the entire
crowd.
No, I watched thousands of people storming
into the capital.
We all watched it with our own eyes.
It was one of the most, but it was the entire
crowd.
Right.
I'm talking about the thousands who did.
And there's no question there's no question
they were whipped up to do so because they
believe their president, who told them the
election had been stolen, fraudulently stolen.
That was a lie, wasn't it?
The president has been insisting so many Americans
have been insisting that our elections are
run legally and transparently.
And when there were shenanigans, obviously,
in so many of the polling areas, the president
has insisted that we look into where all of
these votes had come from before the election
was stolen.
Was it Sarah Palin?
Let's be honest.
Let's be clear.
The election the election was one year after
the election, the election was won.
Let me just say something, and there always
is.
Sarah, election was won.
The election was won fair and square by a
thumping win by Joe Biden.
Do you accept that?
I want to see the our elections and every
polling place is run cleanly now, I was a
governor, so she will not admit that in trying
to defend Trump from any blame about people
storming the Capitol.
She's doing the exact thing that started all
of this to begin with, which is she's now
been asked twice, did Trump lose?
And she's not answering the question and it
continues.
The question was to the election generation
by Joe Biden.
Crazy.
You guys invited me to.
Come on.
Let me just say we didn't answer to the question.
You didn't answer my question.
If you want to if you're going to finish,
OK, why do you answer the questions now?
I'm talking about clean elections, and I know
that shenanigans do take place in elections.
As a governor, I witnessed that also.
And we were always having to crack down through
Division of Elections and the lieutenant governor's
office to answer the questions, who are in
charge of it?
Because, for instance, we had Barack Obama's
right hand man still talk about Obama.
He hasn't been in office for years.
Sarah, you can you can't filibuster us.
Now, listen, let's get back to the question.
The question was, do you accept the Joe Biden.
Let's go.
OK, let's go.
Let's go back.
Let me ask you a question and you answer my
question.
Look, did you go back to the first question?
Did Joe Biden, did Joe Biden you try not to
think of absolute hysteria.
It's it's incredible that there are layers
of hysteria here that we're unable to even
get to because she won't get through the first
level of hysteria, like allowing the question
to simply be repeated and then giving an answer.
Did Joe Biden win?
Here's one more attempt, the rioters on the
Joe Biden win the election.
Can we please finish with the topic, why did
you just skip out over the issue, isn't it
president who is facing impeachment if he
was solely to blame for these criminals?
And there I believe he was to blame for the
coming years.
But I'm asking you, Sarah Palin, whether you
believe Joe Biden won the election.
Well, evidently he did, because he's sworn
in as our president, but no one will convince
me nor anyone else with common sense and a
sense of justice, no one will convince us
that there were not shenanigans going on your
shenanigans.
Explain to me why.
And look, nobody nobody can argue the numbers,
given the number you say rotation, but not
argue against the facts, given that nobody
has produced any facts to prove that was widespread
fraud in the election.
Do you have it now?
Can you show us can you tell me what you know?
Here's the fraud.
Now, don't interrupt me while I finish this
point.
The fraud.
Listen, how many polling areas had to produce
their voter rolls?
And they showed that there were more votes
than there were voters in certain districts.
Where's the fraud?
Sarah, why is that not where is the single
court?
Where is a single case there where it has
a single court in America about fraud?
And you're asking if there was fraud?
I'm telling you where the shenanigans were.
What about all but dead people who vote?
Oh, I don't know, Sarah.
We like this program, Sarah.
I like how Pierce says he likes her on the
program.
I find her completely insufferable and corrosive
to American politics.
He likes her more votes than people.
Wasn't demonstrated anywhere.
Just because they repeat it doesn't make it
true.
And then dead people voting.
Come on, it's been so widely debunked every
time it's been investigated.
Dead people voting were actually a combination
of people who were registered but died before
the election and didn't vote.
Being registered to vote and then dying and
not voting isn't a crime.
It's not shenanigans.
It's not foul play, clerical errors, some
junior senior confusion where like a junior
voted and the vote was counted as their dad,
who might have been dead at the time of the
election.
But it was still only one vote.
It just counted for the wrong person.
That's another thing that happened.
And then also when I believe it was Channel
four in the UK, did an investigation about
this.
A lot of the people that were just claimed
to be dead were actually just alive.
And that's happened to me.
Remember, I was featured in a documentary
about people who were supposedly dead.
And I had to put out a statement saying, I
am I am very much alive right now.
So that is these are all untruths.
And this went on and on.
There are probably about another five or six
minutes of it.
I won't play more, but absolutely horrifying
that Sarah Palin was very close to being the
vice president of the United States.
And had she been vice president, she would
have been, as the phrase goes, a heartbeat
away from being president of the United States.
Really scary stuff.
I'd rather her saying crazy things in Alaska
than in the White House for sure.
But that doesn't make what she's saying any
less outrageous.
We'll have more of this, including commentary,
your commentary on The David Pakman Show Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.